all right let's get right into audience
questions some really good ones this
week first question isolationism versus
non-interventionism this is a good topic
hey David I hear lots of talk when
people discuss Trump's tariffs about
isolationism is this the same as
non-interventionism it is not and this
is a really really important distinction
I am a non interventionist when it comes
to the United States using the military
or using other means to meddle in other
countries whether it comes to being the
world's policeman when there is not
actually a coalition for example that
has decided this is something that the
world is going to take on and it's
abundantly clear that that's what should
be done I am against the United States
meddling in the elections of other
countries or in regime change in other
countries but I am NOT an isolationist
because I see isolationism as a much
further step which is not only do we not
get involved militarily for the defense
of a third country not only do we not do
all of the things that a
non-interventionist would avoid doing
but isolationists can also want to be
isolationist on trade now I believe in
specialization I believe that given the
drastically UNAC unequal distribution of
resources throughout the world which
includes both resources of all kinds I
mean plant and animal resources if you
read Jared Diamond's book Guns Germs and
Steel he outlines how it is not by
chance that some parts of the world
became more successful and earlier than
others it is significantly related to
the flora and fauna that either did or
didn't allow the creation of Agriculture
which developed food surpluses which
allowed specialists to start developing
technology and culture and politics and
governmental type organizations etc etc
so I'm not an isolationist when it comes
to trade I also am NOT an isolationist
when it comes to dealing with refugee
issues around the world dealing with
climate change if you are a pure and
true isolationist you feel no
responsibility to even consider doing
anything about refugee crises in other
places in the world
as a non-interventionist you might
choose not to get involved militarily in
what may be taking place in some other
countries but when what those
circumstances do is generate refugees as
a non isolationist but non
interventionist you can say here's my
how my country is going to get involved
in helping refugees for example
isolationism can also lead to very
extreme immigration policies for example
which I don't favor so there are some
really important differences between
being an isolationist and a non
interventionist I consider myself a non
interventionist who sees military action
as the absolute last resort to be used
only in very particular circumstances
but I am the last thing from an
isolationist and then lastly I mentioned
climate change right now the pollution
climate change disaster that we are
dealing with goes completely beyond
country borders and isolationism is also
a way to in a sense bury our heads in
the sand if it wants to be used this way
and say you know we're worried about our
country we don't care about pollution
going elsewhere even though we have to
deal with pollution coming here from
other countries because pollution
doesn't respect country lines so I think
isolationism is an absolute disaster I
think non-interventionism is very much
in line with the social democracy
philosophy that I sort of by and large
subscribe to let me know if I'm missing
anything or if I'm getting anything
wrong or if you simply disagree with my
conclusions